so I tried to do some research for this
video to try and format my own opinions
on the DLCs ending maybe figure out an
interesting narrative to shape in the
video and I got nothing
the ending is quite abrupt I think
everyone will agree on that I've seen it
described as lackluster disappointing
trains uninspired but also the Matic
insightful true to the series and it's
honestly all of those things to
understand the ending we need to take
the ring cities context into account
this isn't supposed to be a new ending
Dark Souls 3 ended in the killing of the
first flame not the ashen wastes both
entrances to the Ring City come before
the final boss site of the base game we
can argue about whether or not we time
traveling to the future to fight Gale
but from a gameplay perspective that
isn't the end so hoping for a new
conclusive ending that answers our
questions more than the original ending
did doesn't really make sense there is
more to be learned from the ring city
but it's not going to change how we end
the game after the soul of cinder if we
look at ashes of aerion though we can
see what could have been expected from
the ring city ashes of aerion dell
essentially represents a microcosm of
the whole theme and story of Dark Souls
the ring city gives a bit of a small
closer to Aryan those story arendelle
had its own cyclical world that was
being corrupted by its unnatural
prolonging and it ended with the player
burning down the world destroying it so
new one could take place which is
someone explained at the end of the ring
city but this was all basically just a
metaphor for the base game the lore and
characters of arienzo were almost all
new and the DLC didn't really answer any
pre-existing questions from the base
game sure free day was one of ureas
sisters and there were a few lines of
dialogue about that but it didn't really
amount to much the first DLC is a story
parallel yet separate from the vanilla
game looking at the ring city is a
similar theme of separate story to be
fair the ring city does do a better job
of connecting
Cold War it at least takes place in the
same world but once again most of the
lore and story of the second DLC is
either self-contained connected with
arendelle are only slightly referential
of Old War m'dear half light the Judah
caters Fillion or and especially Gale
all fit into one of those three
categories most of the stuff is new
Fillion or technically is connected to
Gwyn but is essentially a completely new
character MIDI are half light are 100%
new however m'dear does have strong
connections with older dragons new piss
and gale is straight out of ashes very
end up the pygmies and the ashen wastes
are really the only characters of old
that we find a better insight to through
this DLC and none of that is necessarily
bad obviously a new DLC should have new
characters and story but with a whole
new cast we can't expect a ton of
answers to old question moving on to the
actual ending Gale in the Dark Soul
our final boss is a slave who gets
powered up off of blood protein shake I
can see how some could have expected
something a bit more grand especially
since that protein shake was basically
the namesake of the serie the Dark Soul
I talked about this in my previous lore
video but this fight is unexpectedly a
really fitting one I said I'm not sure
how to feel about the ending as a whole
and that is still true but to me this
final boss fight is an amazing one Gale
is a nobody and that's huge because
unlike almost every other boss in the
theory that means he's just like us the
chosen undead the bearer of the curse
the ashen one those are all just fancy
titles for nobody the chosen undead was
probably one of millions of undead just
like them the name for the bearer of the
curse literally just means somebody who
got curse and this is in a land in which
the big problem is that the same curse
is afflicting everyone and the ashen one
is only so because they fail that's it
all we did to get our current mystical
title is not succeed in linking the fire
it doesn't really sound like a
my accomplishment to me we always play
as someone who could have been anyone so
that we can all really connect with our
own character we can make our character
whoever we think he or she really ought
to be or if that's the role playing part
of this RPG so this fight with Slade
night Gale is a fight on equal footing
to nobodies who have had the will and
the drive to push forward and complete
the task they set out to do in the world
of mindless hollows we have both seen
the worlds crumble and we both gotten
stronger we both made it to this last
meeting where no one else stand maybe
this is the future and truly all have
died or been eaten by Gale leaving only
us to the final living being Gale has
consumed the dark soul to make sure that
his lady the painter and areand L would
be able to use his blood now the blood
of the Dark Soul to finish her painting
but the Dark Soul has corrupted him and
we have to put him down maybe she knew
we would be the one to do it whatever
the case is mind having left him Gale is
now buzzard and he rampages for the
remaining part of the Dark Soul that
rests in us once we defeat Gale that's
basically it there's no cutscene not
even a fade to black we can go back to
the painter and airy endo and give her
the blood of the Dark Soul with that we
get her ending dialogue and that's that
DN
my passion one with this reliable in the
world
please tell me my name after name this
painting after date my
I will painful flower of that name to be
cold and
nothing more to Bro confusing what are
we supposed to do now
shouldn't there be some kind of
conclusion after the last boss fight in
the last dlc of the last Dark Souls I
can never say with the intentions of the
end of this dlc where but what I can say
is that the ending for better or for
worse is very dark Souls do you have a
million more question do you feel you
deserve a better explanation for all the
crazy and expansive pieces of lore that
have made up this series well then
welcome to Dark Souls you will fit right
in
in one of my earlier videos I said that
I hoped we could get a little more
closure because this was the last piece
of Dark Souls content ever but it looks
like we got the usual treatment the
ending was almost not there but we can
look to the painter and see that there
is something like an ending in her she's
making a new peaceful world something
almost every character and the souls
born franchise would benefit from we
don't know much more than that it'll be
cold and dark but comforting because I
view the canonical ending of the base
game as the age of dark ending the one
where we have the fire keeper stop the
fire from being relinked this dlc ending
kind of just serves as a slight
expansion on that I probably shouldn't
call it the age of dark ending as that
has some different connotations possibly
I think something more like ending the
related thing it's a pretty bad title
for an ending but it captures the idea
of what I think the ending is and that's
stopping the real inking of the first
flame returning to the actual topic
the painter sounds like she's painting
an age of no more linking of the first
flame maybe as we let the fire go out
the world crumbles we do see this at the
kiln of the first flame the world is
falling apart and getting all mismatched
it might be up to the painter to
construct the new world that will rise
out of the ruins of this fading age that
seems reasonable unacceptable to me but
honestly it's just a theory so
this DLCs ending is essentially just a
new dark world will be made that's about
it
one thing to note is that in the ashen
waste before the fight the Sun shines
brightly on the demon it does seem to be
almost gone off the horizon but it's
clearly still there if we look to the
other direction we see Knight looming
encroaching upon the enlightened realm
already covering most of the vast dunes
and after the fight the Sun is gone they
desires over the age of dark or maybe
grey or not linking the fire whatever
this new age is is descending upon us
the Dark Soul this series namesake is
being used to make a new cool peaceful
world a world that will probably be
devoid of all the elements that are so
characteristic of this one like the Dark
Soul in the first flame the abyss and
everything else
the painter named the painting actress
it's not she'll name it the painted
world of that she wanted Gale to find a
home in even though he won't maybe we
will be able to the only thing that
carries over from the world of Dark
Souls to his new world is us a player
this is a perfect metaphor for from
software moving forward they end the
world of this game filled a new game on
the old worlds remnants and the only
feature that remained completely the
same through both of them is us the
players who will almost surely check out
whatever from has up text actually over
the course of writing this script
narrating it and making this video I
think I'm pretty happy with this ending
looking back at it Dark Souls is open
and so the age we fought and died in so
many times is over - it's being replaced
by something new something new that's
built off the foundation of the old
something we're not quite sure of yet
but maybe in the future we'll find out
very symbolic but from software
themselves
the peaceful ending to such a rage
inducing series this was probably one of
the more confusing videos I've done even
for Dark Souls trying to tie up loose
ends and explaining the endings of this
game is always a Herculean task
Lorelei's so I appreciate all of you
watching and hope you'll continue to
stick around I think I have a pretty
cool idea for a video about Fillion or
coming up sometime in the near future
then look out for that and if you want
to stay up to date with my videos and
stuff you can head over to my Twitter I
sometimes update over there and if there
are more people expecting that NATO
would update more thanks again for
watching and leave any of your own lore
ideas in the comments below or anything
you think I should make a video peace
out everyone it's done